Salaam alaikum peace be unto you welcome
to the D show now most of you out there
have heard of the inspirational series
inspiring you buy in short film segments
really short and sweet talking about the
beautiful aspects of Islam about charity
dispelling the myths of terrorism and
many other aspects that now through a
movie form they have gotten some actors
and really in a fabulous job and I'm
here with the producer and director of
the inspirational series to talk about
this when we come back here Andy show
don't worry this is the
this is the thing you know this is the
dangedest Athene jus mean you know this
is the jewel Salaam alaikum peace be
unto you what Salam aleikum Salam or the
crown well I mean how are you thanks for
having me here I'm doing great hunger
love what about of you good hamdullah
hamdullah now you're the director
producer of the inspirational series
that's correct tell us a little about
this well the series itself it started
it's a funny fact that started as the
people who funded the project asked me
to do a project where we have the Imam
standing against a green screen telling
stories from ceará so we try to convince
the producers to just let's taken a
dramatic approach to it to make it more
entertaining to youth so we started you
know we created that sky that character
are used in which he faces daily
challenges in his life and he seeks the
answer in the syrah of the Prophet peace
be upon him so what is special I think
about inspiration is there is no
preaching no direct preaches but there
is a guy who exactly like us and he's he
himself is learning and teaching at the
same time this is beautiful what
inspired you now to create something
like this I think the most common
problem we faced with youth when they
read the cedar or they listen to the
seed of the Prophet they say that this
is very interesting but this guy was you
know grade in his time you know and our
time is totally different and I can't
relate to his Syrah so this is what that
was the main motivation that we needed
to show the youth that the seal your
current life your everyday life is so
much similar to our prophet life the
challenges you're facing he faces
similar he faced similar challenges but
only the appearances has
you know are different but it's very
similar so this series trying to prove
this now tell us you with your 14 +
years experience in movie making and in
this industry you could have chosen a
route towards bollywood or hollywood but
you took this approach now and obviously
there is so much more rewards here I
mean a whole new world opens up in
Hollywood but what made you at one point
were you thinking like okay like let me
let me go in that direction what steered
you more towards this right direction
this is a fabulous route that you've
taken I think before going to filmmaking
I was having this you know this goal in
my life I wanted to transfer to convey
this these beautiful messages to the
whole word so I entered filmmaking
putting this ahead I need to do this and
I always say that the our Prophet peace
be upon him he went up a hill in Mecca
to be heard and seen and this held today
is the film theaters and the cable TV
and the YouTube and i really want to
convey this to the people and i and i
think there's many struggles you know
because there's no Islamic media
productions of the West unfortunately or
very rare a chances so this road is
still you know it's it's empty and
there's no people working here it's
tough it's very tough but I think I
really enjoy it I love it I love to be
chala Arab to be a pain near this path
and just to inspire more youth to go
with this road it's amazing because now
how many people have you seen some of
the feedback because through the media
outlets obviously now we're able to to
reach masses of
have you seen some of the feedback now
work the feedback have you begin yeah
definitely this is an extraordinary
chance and era we live in because we as
you say we really receive we pause the
video and like five seconds later you
see people typing and responding and
commenting on the video and we learn
from this a lot so for example of our
inspiration series we read unbelievable
hundred like comments from non-muslims
all around the world saying that well
this version of Islam we are watching
and you're serious is different from the
one we watch on whatever Fox News ABC
News and whatever so hamdullah we we
found that this is uh this is an extra
very chance to reach the whole world and
our chala we intend to do a second
season of respiration you're going to do
a second season now many people ask me
you know constantly we'll get some
emails and people will say look how do
we get involved in the media you know we
want to do this what you're doing we
want to somehow contribute right people
are fascinated with the media we're
gonna go and take a break right now when
we come back this is what you also you
try to inspire people give them some
direction on how to get involved in the
media is that right yeah so let me come
back we're going to talk about this here
on the D show don't go anywhere please
subscribe to the dvo follow us on our
official Facebook and Twitter pages in
the links below please also help support
the V show by making a donation in the
link below back here on the D show with
the producer director of the series now
that you're going to do a part two to
also soon tell us a little about what
would something coming for the for the
part two of this what do you guys how
long is a series how many how many
episodes were conducted in part in the
first part what did you have 7 8 9 12 12
episodes maybe 12 episodes in the summer
we will have a mini second season with
six episodes now each one is uniquely
there about what 56 minutes yeah that's
right how did you figure out the order
you got some dealing with charity
kindness to your neighbor dispelling the
myth of terrorism what else are some of
these topics that's right are we attack
as many different morals like the women
of our life women understand the family
understand the honesty the trust all
these morals each episode that will take
and you know tackle certain morals of
the prophets allows it was a great way
to do Dawa to share this message now
through a short film format many people
they want to get involved i'm sure
you've been you've been asked a lot of
people are excited they see this and
they want to contribute you follow me so
what advice do you give people out there
who want to get involved in media okay
the first thing i say try to take a
filmmaking course and intensive short
one in any film school or institute in
your city state area whatever and you
need this you need this infrastructure
to start and second try to get involved
with people already working in the
filter just trying to attend as a guest
watching behind the camera how things
are done this will get an priceless
experience here third start doing your
own short and small projects by any
means we have by your phone iPad
whatever tools we have to film and after
doing this this first project show it to
people with you know experience and
listen to their feedback and this is how
you get started this is the best way I
can think of one one aspect here is we
know that when we invite to something
good right when you have a movie like
this and now people get inspired they
get inspired to give in charity they get
inspired to be more into their Dean they
see that you know Islam doesn't call
people to anything that is against
humanity it calls to goodness and the
people behind this now with the right
intention you're going to get the reward
it keeps going and going as more people
going to spires right and more that if
they're motivated now to do good you get
the reward now someone might on the
other hand be making some some videos
out there they want to get into the
media and they have a ambition a drive
but now they might be making videos that
now they're they're not really
reflecting
these videos aren't inspiring people to
good and you know there's there's people
just you know for trying to get more
views out there they're doing some crazy
things right when anything what do you
have to say for people like that that
that to kind of get them more into
making positive videos that have a
positive influence in people lives I
think the most important fact is to
think about the greater goodness always
not yourself and and to be famous or to
be whatever rich and I anything these
things will happen will you no will come
eventually but what really matters is
you know this moral a loss is to
whenever you do any project you just
think I want to do this for the sake of
Allah and by having this nia allah will
bless you the whole work and everything
else will come you know getting famous
all these things i look at you know that
this advantage of being famous i'll even
this I look at this as being you know
use and I a tool just to deliver your
ideas but just yonni try to make this
purest me out of the most Pantera ya
allah i want to do this for your sake
and for your sake only and suddenly all
everything will the whole Road will be
much more clear it's panel on you will
see the toffee coming from a las
Americana we're going to take a break
but you heard it that's it you've gotten
here it here on the DS show sincerity
saying that I want to do this for you
for you a lot that's where it starts
will then be right back with more here
on a Dean shoulder
be worship Jesus no you don't worship
Jesus worship the god of Jesus you
thought you worship the god of Jesus the
one who Jesus fell on his face and pray
to that's when we worship now do we only
believe in Mohammed no we believe in all
the prophets to start from the first
migrated I'm Adam to Abraham look her
son Jacob and the tribe Moses King Jesus
the last pop was only muhammad saw some
people your father so we believe in all
those messages you mentioned who you
mentioned we might and there's many more
so we believe it out all of them yes all
the ones that are mentioned in the Quran
and other than the other day you know
you don't worship tell me what you wash
up a lot who's a crater but it's part of
the belief to believe in these messages
yes your name like Jesus wasn't even
done we don't worship them don't worship
them yes please subscribe to the dvo
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below please
also help support the show by making a
donation in the link below back here on
the DS show with the producer director
of the inspirational series now many
people they cut a lot of corners and
they will incorporate things that are
not necessarily Islamic they might be
displeasing to the crater right you guys
actually like what was your criteria now
because you did everything now in there
you know that you didn't compromise in
the deed and this is very important
because you could end up doing yeah a
lot of work and then at the end is not
accepted by Allah and so so this is this
is a we commend you for that talk a
little bit about this well how long this
is a real challenge because most of the
business in the filmmaking gates and I
saw on the other side where you know
it's every commercials the materialism
the filmmaking that you know and while
picking the side of with morals you will
find yourself suddenly alone and with no
funding etc and
this is really challenging but spinola
the life lost Hannah Tyler showered me
with his blessings and whenever I try to
do a project and when I started working
on this inspiration series i didn't have
funding and suddenly sha la la when you
work in the project the funding will
come and people would get interested so
this is a message I delivered to the
youth while you're putting your leg on
the first step you will might be might
not be able to see the second step but
do it and don't call all along loss man
Tyler will will push you further and
will give you the way so it's very
challenging I'm not here to give any
comfort or false hopes or anyone but
it's really challenging but we need it
so badly and a la strada I will help you
to continue with this world this is a
proof itself because you see that now
you're living testimony that through
this there there is an avenue that you
guys took that's a WoW avenue that over
here you don't have to have naked men or
women you know in the movies you don't
have to compromise and swearing and
doing all sorts of things that are
immoral part but I did it in a nice
clean way that now everybody can benefit
from Muslim non-muslim it's for
everybody exactly we're trying to prove
this that you can make successful
productions without you know doing her
own things yes you're able to do that
this is amazing what else do you have
coming up in the future well besides it
part to Abraham some film yeah you have
your connections man so I is still a
working title mr. Brown film and it
talks about a man here in the modern
America and this man faces this man walk
is working in a journey of seeking the
truth and we found that this
by the way it's based on a true story we
found that this journey is so similar to
the journey of the prophet of Mohammed I
still AM because he was you know looking
for where is God whose God and we found
this very pretty interesting because
like 2,000 3,000 years later with around
we have a man here in America facing the
same challenges and seeking the very
same eternal truth you know that man
were looking for which is God and it's a
very pretty interesting film and I won't
talk much about this hour I'll keep it
to cholla till will everything you are
ready to talk about it but it's coming
in the near future soon as y'all are we
working on it we still in a pea
production we're still writing script
yeah before we leave now tell us again
you discussed it you discussed it but
again just going over it again for the
people that are excited they want to get
involved in the media they want to
contribute what are the steps that need
to take add to what you said earlier
leave them went on something that they
can a direction yeah sure again anyone
who is interested to enter the
filmmaking domain I I would say start by
studying it take a short filmmaking
course at a film institute and i would
say avoid academic study long study
years with a master a bachelor this is
not useful according to my experience
take a short course like a four weeks
eight weeks three months this additional
duration and after that start to mingle
start to try to get close to people with
professional people working in the film
making business and just to 10 just to
carry their bags whatever and you will
get the experience the hands on
experience and third start filming your
own project and even as a man one man
short film at reddit to edit it yourself
even act and it's no problem whatever
tools you have just use it just to test
yourself and after that take your film
and give it to professional people and
listen to their feedback this is the
best cycle I can think of
like to thank you for being with us he
on the door thank you for having nice as
Uggla hon thank ya from LA and there you
have it you've asked Eddie look what
advice can you give us so we brought a
person of 14 + years experience in
filmmaking moviemaking and the first
thing that we start is with the right
intention asking the crater look to
guide us and to make sure that we are
sincere in this effort and we don't
compromise make sure we do it the Halal
way the Halal style without compromising
the deed and then from there move
forward he's giving you some of these
steps hopefully you can benefit from it
and we'll see you next time inshallah
God willing until then peace be with you
please subscribe to the dvo follow us on
our official Facebook and Twitter pages
in the links below please also help
support the V show by making a donation
in the link below